in all of our conversations about demand
curves so far i've been generally
talking about
price
driving quantity so for example we've
been saying
using say this demand curve right here
for a new car in terms of how many would
be sold per day we would say things like
well look if we price it at sixty
thousand dollars per car this is in
thousands of dollars if we price it at
sixty thousand dollars per car we are
going to sell one car and if we price it
at fifty thousand dollars a car we're
going to sell two cars so the way that
i've been talking about it is given a
price how many are we actually going to
sell what i want to do in this video is
think about it the other way around
we're gonna look at the exact same
demand curve the exact same relationship
between price and quantity but we're
going to conceptualize it in our heads
in a slightly different way we're going
to think about it in terms of quantity
quantity driving price and to think of
it that way imagine that we are the
producers of this given model of a of a
new car
and we we go the other way we don't say
how many will we sell at a price of
sixty thousand dollars or how many are
we going to sell at a price of fifty
thousand dollars we'll go from the point
of views what if we only produce one car
a week if we only produced one car a
week how much could we get for that car
and let's say somehow you're able to
figure that out you're able to read
people's minds or you have some type of
a market study and when you ask that
question you're like look if you only
allowed one car to be sold each week you
determine that on in that week there's
going to be somebody somebody's going to
think that it's worth sixty thousand
dollars to buy that car and so that
person their willingness to pay that
person is
is is going to be willing to trade 60
000 they're going to they're they're
going to be willing to forego what else
they could have bought for that 60 000
and instead they want that car and so
then you would plot that point right
over there if you only had one unit you
could sell it for sixty thousand dollars
now let's go let's keep asking ourselves
for more units now let's say what if we
wanted to sell two units
well if you if you wanted to sell two
units you could definitely you could
definitely sell one unit for sixty
thousand dollars assuming that you you
could get that first person
but that second person this might have
been the person just wants your car so
badly it just resonated with them in
some way but for that second unit the
the second person who's going to need to
buy your car might not be the as excited
about it and so that second person that
second person will only be willing to
forgo 50 000
that second person would be willing to
forego 50. so if you wanted to sell two
units if you want it if you insist on
selling two units and if you're assuming
you're going to give the same price for
everyone we'll talk about in the future
how you might give different prices to
different people but assuming you want
to give the same price to everyone
you're going to have to sell your car
for 50 dollars now clearly that first
person is definitely going to jump at it
they're going to be able to get the car
for more than they were willing to pay
more than what it was worth to them more
than there
more than the benefit for them but if
you want two people now you're going to
have to set this up for 50 000. now the
same logic now what if we want to sell
three cars what if we want to sell three
cars a week
well if we price it at fifty thousand
we'll definitely get those first two but
the third person isn't gonna the third
person might not jump the third person
isn't going to be as excited about it or
needed as much as these first two and so
you do a market study or you're able to
read people's minds you're like look the
third person for the market the marginal
benefit let me write this word down the
marginal benefit the marginal benefit
for this next for this for the next unit
the next unit is going to be forty
thousand dollars to get that next buyer
and it could be multiple buyers buying
each unit or it could be one buyer
buying all of the units maybe it's some
type of a car rental company saying oh
we don't need to get if for three of
these cars i'm not i'm not as excited
about it anymore my marginal benefit is
lower and this is really the same
marginal benefit that we talked about
when we talked about the ppf the
production possibilities frontier in
that we talked about it very explicitly
in terms of trade-offs in terms of
opportunity cost here we're measuring
the marginal benefit in terms of price
but price really can be viewed as a
foregone opportunity if you spend forty
thousand dollars on this car you're
making the decision not to spend forty
thousand dollars on something else a
down payment on a house or a nice boat
or whatever else it might be so really
what we're doing is at any point in this
curve this really is the marginal
benefit for that next buyer that
marginal benefit to the market of that
next that next unit of whatever you are
producing and so i really just want to
make it this is a very different way of
viewing the exact same demand curve
before we said okay if we want to price
it at fifty thousand how many are we
going to sell now we're saying if we
wanna sell only two units where can we
price it we can price it at fifty
thousand dollars and if we wanna go from
two to three units we're going to have
to price it at the marginal benefit of
that third unit to the market and it
could be the marginal benefit to that
next consumer convincing that next
consumer to say hey it is worth it to
buy this car let's price it at forty
thousand dollars now i'm gonna leave you
there in this video but what i'm gonna
think about is depending on where you
price it let's say that we decide that
we want to sell four units every week
and so we say well look there's to get
that fourth person to buy this car we
have to price the car at 30 thousand
dollars
we're going to talk about in the next
video is if you did that if this is
where you decide to price it so that you
can sell four units
these other people got really good deals
the first unit could have gone for much
more the second unit could have still
also gone for a good bit not as much as
the first unit the third unit could have
gone for a little bit less than the
second unit but still more than what you
ended up selling things for so we're
going to talk about this idea right over
here that some of these consumers are
getting more for their money than what
they have to pay or at least in their
own minds they are